on
[Musique]
un homme de 65 ans se fait prendre en
photo avec sa jeune mariée de 12 ans en
plein times square à new york la scène
choc les passants ces jeunes c'est
d'elle
secret pour lui
je
[Musique]
la vidéo visionnée 22 millions de fois
est une mise en scène orchestrée par so
you tube et choqué de découvrir que le
mariage d'enfants était légale aux états
unis avec le consentement d'un parent ou
d'un juge injuste que la moitié des
états n'ont même pas d'âge minimal pour
le mariage
selon l'organisme unchained en dix ans
il y a eu aux états unis 248 mariages
précoces mais le phénomène reste
marginal en occident
si on compare aux pays en développement
au sénégal
une femme sur trois et mariées avant
l'âge de 18 ans ici dans la région de
kolda 68 % des filles subissent un
mariage précoce
mes parents ont voulu me donner en
mariage au village mais je leur ai fait
comprendre que je ne voulais pas me
marier parce que je n'ai pas l'âge
d'avoir un et pour cette fillette dit
avoir trouvé le courage de résister à
ses parents en adhérant au club des
jeunes filles de son quartier ces
groupes organisent des activités des
jeux de rôle des débats autour du thé
des soirées dansantes qui sensibilise
les adolescentes aux dangers des
mariages et des grossesses précoces
ces clubs sont en partie financés par le
canada
on veut que nos jeunes filles soient
éduqués la première des choses faut
éviter qu'elle soit mariée à 13,1 et
enceinte à 14 on veut investir 150
millions de dollars sur cinq ans dans
les petites organisations locales de
femmes donc on veut vraiment travailler
avec les organisations avec les femmes
locales depuis une quinzaine d'années
notamment a investi la plus grosse part
de son aide internationale dans les
agences de l'onu ou détriment des ong
canadiennes et des organismes le coup en
afrique
la ministre veut revenir à un contact
plus direct avec le terrain pour changer
les mentalités
on est capable d'avoir la conversation
avec les chefs traditionnels et chefs
religieux avec les parents autant les
parcs les maires dont c'est possible
quand on s'y prend bien de de faire
progresser d'avoir cette discussion et 2
de changer la mentalité pour protéger
les jeunes filles
cette adolescente a réussi à changer la
tradition familiale
le clip des jeunes filles de son
quartier n'a encouragé à parler à ses
parents de son rêve de devenir
mécanicienne maintenant nous nous
entretenons régulièrement avec nos
parents ce qui n'existait pas auparavant
entre nous et nos parents goudeau dit
que les adolescentes du club sans
courage ça donne des trucs pour résister
aux avances des hommes et éviter les
grossesses ici sophie langlois radio
canada montréal
[Musique]